okay
they were once the backbone of the
Industrial Revolution today Britain's
Heritage steam Railways pulled day
Trippers rather than steel but there's a
risk these beloved locomotives could be
reaching the end of the line
so this is the last of the Welsh steam
coal what we've got here the UK's last
coal mine for steam trains suddenly
closed in January and the war in Ukraine
has cut off the secondary Market of
Russian coal our Locos were built to run
on Welsh steam coal and with it no
longer available we've got to look for
alternative sources if we get to a stage
where the cost of coal is such that
we're not running profitably then
ultimately no Heritage no Heritage
Railway is going to be able to operate
you see
the cold shortage is getting so bad some
Railways are cutting back their
timetables with others looking abroad
for fuel
with UK supplies drying up Railways are
looking elsewhere this coal was shipped
in from Colombia but bringing in fossil
fuels from thousands of miles away may
not be the long-term solution
there are more than 150 Heritage
Railways in the UK which together burn
26 000 tons of coal each year some are
testing alternative man-made fuels but
it could be years before they're ready
we're very responsible uh industry very
responsible sector we first started work
on alternative fuels three years ago
thinking there's plenty of time it's not
as simple as simply saying oh here's an
alternative there's a lot of chemical
analysis has to be done the fuel
problems come at a busy time with steam
Railways a popular draw for all
generations doesn't really matter what
age you are you know little children
like those little boys over there older
people like me that just takes me back
to when I was a child that you can see
loads of animals because usually they're
on the field yeah that's my favorite
part is it better than driving in the
car yes does it cross your mind about
the sort of environmental impacts
probably increasingly yes
um and there's a really difficult
tension there isn't there because
there's a lot of Heritage to this but
the environmental impact is really
difficult isn't it some Heritage
Railways have just a month's coal left
in the yard keeping these trains on
track for the year ahead
could prove a difficult challenge Dan
White is Sky News in gloucestershire